if you want to learn in one video some
of the best advice from the shark tank
sharks then this video is for you
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that amazing gift you
have inside you be unleash that you can
have a positive impact on yourself your
family your community and the world set
of help you on your journey today we're
gonna look at six
killer lessons from the shark tank
sharks enjoy
I had a job out of college working for a
bank for a short period of time Mellon
Bank and I am decided to well first it
might have been ink magazine this away
back when but there was an article about
using changing something in how you
deduct social how you save Social
Security from employees paychecks and
literally hadn't been working there for
three weeks and so I sent it to the CEO
of Mellon Bank hey I thought you might
be interested it's literally some guy he
never heard of and I got an OPEC said
thank you and nothing and okay you look
my whole job my whole motive in taking a
job working for somebody was to help
them become more profitable that's the
way I always looked at it and then I
started a rookies Club where I reached
out to some executives and all the
people who had started at the same time
at Mellon Bank we don't go out and get a
drink and we'd get this executive start
and I didn't like run it through my boss
or anything and so my boss at the time
calls me in and said you're doing this
is I said yeah I think he's gonna say
great it's just her screaming at me and
Raymond Meade how could you do this you
go everything through me you work for me
yeah yeah so I knew I wasn't destined
there and then I left and I went down to
ended up down in Dallas and got a job
working for a company called your
business software and we were we sold
software and and I didn't know anything
about software I took one computer class
at Indiana and kind of cheated to pass
but not that I condone that but
and so I had a customer and I thought
might stay up all night teach reading I
figure you know computers were new and
technology was new this technology was
new so no we had a head start on me
because it was changing so rapidly like
it is today that if I just put in the
time I can learn as much as anybody else
and so I taught myself I'd stay up late
reading software manuals taught myself
different little simple programming
languages and it kept on getting bigger
and bigger and better and better but it
was at a retail store and one of my
responsibilities was to come in
sweep the floor wipe down the windows
and open the store and I had a customer
who wanted me to come out there and
close the deal and it was a fifteen
thousand dollar deal fifteen hundred
dollar commission to me told my boss he
said no you need to be there to open the
store and I made the executive decision
that I was gonna go get the check
because you know I was living six guys
in a three-bedroom apartment sleeping on
the floor and this check meant I could
like not use the same holiday in towels
with holes in them that I'd stolen you
know mom but anyway so I went and picked
up the check thank you when I came back
and gave the check to my boss all would
be forgiven and you know the sales cures
all fired me fired me and so those
back-to-back experiences confirmed what
I already knew that that I was a yes
employee and then I better start my
I'm pretty happy guy yeah you know I
think that's one of the keys to success
I read an article that the difference
between successful people and people
that struggle are successful people
exude joy Jeff if you're not a happy guy
and other people don't want to hang out
right why would they hang out with right
if you're miserable and nobody wants to
spend time with you how are you ever
gonna get ahead yeah advice from plane I
remember when we were really young this
lesson was taught to me by my dad and I
kind of had a miserable day at school
because you know the kids make fun of
you you're an immigrant you're poor and
I came home and I was feeling sorry for
myself and my dad came home it's gonna
sound so melodramatic he walked a couple
miles to the factory I was a blue-collar
guy and I came home a just stood there
and I was complaining about my day where
were you living we were living in like a
and oh this stage would be three times
the size and a little partisan
oh my gosh oh it wasn't it wasn't
Pleasant and my dad was just standing
there and I was complaining and feeling
sorry for myself and my dad looks at me
and says never complain you should
always be happy with the opportunities
given you and that was it and so you you
know if you feel that big
recently I was with a bunch of other
investors who I respect and they brought
me a deal and I wanted to be part of it
but it didn't feel right and I wrote
millions of dollars on that one and it
just didn't feel right and I lost it all
within two years so investors dress
their got dinner
absolutely and trust you but what about
you said earlier don't be emotional and
sometimes forgot know this this is a
barometer of risk it's something an
internalized for an investor that says I
don't feel comfortable it's not about
emotion it's just don't write that check
that was recently the first time I
didn't listen to that and I lost
everything so now my radar is up I
listen to my gut it's not an emotion
it's an index of risk and you get it as
you age you become a better investor
every year if only I could live to 200
I'd be really good
let me tell you rejection is the big
kahuna in all entrepreneurship okay show
me somebody who could take a hit I'll
show you a good entrepreneur I don't
know if I made that up okay but it's all
in how well you get back up and you know
what I have fun by the way because if
you think about it great salespeople
make a couple million dollars a year
selling apartments in York City which
migrate sales people do great
entrepreneurs all the business comes
from them they manage your own business
they hire staff they're entrepreneurs
and you know what I found only
difference between the superstars were
making the loans a year the person's
barely getting by
the only difference not contacts not how
hard they work some people work just as
hard and don't make any money right it's
how long they feel sorry for themselves
once they get hit some people could take
a hit and milk it the two weeks they're
at their desk they look like they're
working but they're not working mentally
they're out there the great salespeople
will take the hit and then they jump
right back up as though they've been
hurt just as much as the next guy but
they work right through and keep going
let me tell you if you have that skill
you should be an entrepreneur because
you will be paying well for it the
single best thing I do more than
anything else I can do building
businesses for myself and these other
people was just being for myself is I
fail well I fall on my face let me tell
you nobody is better at pretending I'm
not thinking of a quick cover up trying
to keep moving and you want to know in
that act itself of getting back up fast
you always stumble onto something good
and you want to know one other thing
this is I'm not a religious person
because I was raised so god damn
religious I don't want ever think about
it again but I do believe once you put
your mind and going forward on anything
it is almost like a battle cry that goes
out in the universe and the world
rallies around you
just comes here for again and again so
to have that kind of good faith that I'm
just getting back up here if I'm gonna
get slammed life is fair in its own
weird way in that way in building
businesses you will be swept up by some
lucky chance it happened to me every
time I got back up
what change in my life wasn't the fact
that I wanted to become a millionaire
well change in my life was the fact that
I wanted to make these clothes for
myself for other people because nobody
respected this market I was doing
something I loved and then all of a
sudden it started to take off can you
tell me a little bit about that once
that passion finally you know caught on
you know and you finally decided you
know this is something that I want to
move forward with and a little bit about
that first product and how it kind of
all took off from there and then did you
ever decide you know at that point was
like no slowing you down right yeah well
you know when that passion when that
when that thing grabs ahold of you and
as they say when the needle is it
finally in the vein and you're you're
really hooked it's like being in love
it's like um
you know you thought you thought you
like somebody when you were 13 14 years
old and you know that was just something
new and it was puppy love but when
you're 22 23 years old and you're out
this and they're making life decisions
and saying I could see myself with this
person for the rest of my life and
you're getting butterflies every time
you see them that's what it is when you
have a business and you have a company
that you love you can't see anything
else and you you know I would have
dressed people till today for free if I
could and I'm sure you hear that for
everybody else you know an artist will
rap and sing you know any time they can
be seen and just like the kids in school
walls got kicked out in special edible
comedians they can't help but they know
that that's the biggest bully in the
schoolyard and they can't help it but
crack a joke even though they're gonna
get their head cracked open but they
just love what they're doing and that's
just how it was as a business you know I
fell in love with FUBU when I when I saw
that first person walking down the
street with my product on
to me an entrepreneur is somebody who
will do whatever it takes right they're
driven they are a type personalities
they it's like they don't know the word
no and that's always been my mantra I
know no knows just how can I so when I
see that person I know that no matter
what even if they have to pivot you know
which is something that happens maybe
this isn't the best idea but something
else is and you're gonna change it
they're still gonna make it because they
have what it takes to be a successful
entrepreneur and when you started out
did you have someone that was like your
mentor that you looked up to know
anybody influential no what was really
interesting is I know I really didn't I
just had an idea I was always thinking
of things I was always creative and had
no plan on which to make products or be
an inventor I didn't even really like
business I really did that was boring to
me I'm but I had an idea and I had a
dream and I thought people need this
product and I got the bug and once you
get the bug and you realize you can do
it then you just keep doing more and
more and more thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know one who is your favorite shark and
why and to what lesson did you learn
from this video that you can immediately
apply somehow to your life for your
business leave it down the comments
below I'm really curious to find out so
thank you guys for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love I'll see you soon
once long yeah the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details